bonjour à tous Dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre une table ronde
organisée par l'OPEX l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques une
table ronde portant sur la filière
hydrogène énergie pour l'OPEX il faut
imaginer des solutions de stockage
d'énergie afin de pouvoir développer les
énergies renouvelables à grande échelle
à cet égard l'hydrogène est une piste
prometteuse mais alors comment produire
de l'hydrogène comment le transporter
comment le stocker et combien ça coûte
c'est à toutes ces questions que cette
table ronde que je vous propose de voir
tout de suite réponds l'hydrogène est
l'élément le plus répandu dans l'univers
mais qu'il est généralement accessible
sur notre planette sous forme combinée
avec de l'oxygène ou du carbone il est
donc en général nécessaire de dépenser
de l'énergie pour commencer à séparer
l'hydrogène de ses composés c'est
pourquoi l'hydrogène est associé comme
un vecteur énergétique et non pas comme
une source d'énergie l'Institut français
du pétrole énergie nouvelle a toutefois
engagé une étude sur les sources
d'hydrogène naturel Monsieur François
kalaidan directeur adjoint ressources
énergétiques de
l'ifpn va à présent nous en présenter
les principaux résultats il a commencé à
intervenir tout à l'heure peut-être
pourra-t-il nous donner une idée des
quantités d'hydrogène qui pourraiit être
extraite de ces sources et des
investissements qui seraient aussi
nécessaires pour pouvoir y parvenir je
vous donne la parole
oui je vous en prie monsie bien je vous
remercie de nous avoir invité IFP
énergie nouvelle à intervenir dans dans
cette journée j'ai bien conscience qu'on
est un petit peu exogène par rapport à
tout ce qui ce qui a été dit et donc mon
mon propos qui va être assez bref mon
propos est et d'illustrer finalement que
de parler de l'hydrogène en tant que
vecteur énergétique est un peu réducteur
d'ailleurs le mot réducteur et réduction
reviendra en en fil rouge dans ma
présentation
puisque l'hydrogène est produit
naturellement par le système terre et
donc à ce
titre peut être qualifié de
d'énergie produite par notre notre globe
donc réducteur réduction c'est c'est
bien le le cas de le dire puisque
finalement l'eau qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'eau c'est un oxyde d'hydrogène donc
passer de de l'eau à à l'hydrogène ça
résulte d'un processus de réduction et
qui dit réduction c'est il faut avoir le
la contrepartie qui est une oxydation et
finalement si on arrive à avoir
naturellement un système
d'oxydoréduction et bien on voit qu'on
peut produire de façon
continue de l'hydrogène par réduction de
l'eau pour autant qu'on arrive par
exemple à oxyder un métal
corrélativement par
exemple un minéral contenant du fer le
fer étant dans un état fer de et qu'on
puisse faire passer ce ce fer de en fer
3 donc si vous avez dans la
nature des des minéraux fériques qui
encore une capacité d'oxydation vu qu'il
y a quand même pas mal d'eau dans la
nature pour peu que les conditions
soient réunies et bien on voit cassz
naturellement c'est le cas de le dire on
peut produire de l'hydrogène de façon
naturelle donc vecteur pas pas
uniquement mais source d'énergie oui
alors bon nous avons fait des
communiqués de presse cette année
là-dessus ces communiqués de presse sont
pas là pour dire vous savez il y a de la
production naturelle d'hydrogène vous le
saviez pas on vous l'apprend on n pas
cette prétention là on sait bien que
dans les dorsales
médio océanique notamment celle qu'on
connaît bien la médioatlantique qui qui
émerge en Islande et
bien il y a de la production d'hydrogène
alors cette production d'hydrogène
d'ailleurs est associé à
d'autres d'autres constituants comme
comme l'azote comme l'hélium comme le
méthane aussi et les évents qui sont
localisés sur les dorsales médiau
océanique ont des des productions de
chaque évent et donc il y en a des des
multitudes chaque évent peut avoir des
productions de 5 à 10 millions de mètr
cubes d'hydrogène par an c'est pas c'est
pas rien donc c'est connu et donc on a
réellement là une source d'énergie il se
trouve que aller chercher de l'hydrogène
au milieu de l'océan c'est quand même un
peu compliqué et donc même si c'est
connu c'est pas du tout envisageable
d'un point de vue industriel mais ça
guide ça guide la
réflexion il existe donc dans la sur
notre globe terrestre des endroits où il
y a une production de d'hydrogène
massive et euh est-ce que et c'est là
que nous on est intervenu finalement
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres endroits sur
la planète un peu moins exotique que le
fond des océans situés dans la ride de
médioatlantique ou médioocéanique par
des milliers de de mètres de fond est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres endroits d'autres
occurrences
possibles de production d'hydrogène
naturel et
finalement par quel quel système ça peut
se passer quels sont les mécanismes qui
président à la production
d'hydrogène alors il y a grosso modo il
y a
deux deux options hein de de production
d'hydrogène il y a
une première
qui finalement concerne les les massifs
alors il y a quelques termes géologique
massif folitique ou péridotique donc ce
sont des roches à l'état
réduit qui sont des roches souvent qui
sont formées par très grande profondeurs
et qui sont effectivement riche en en
fer et en fer à un niveau de par exemple
faire de donc il a une capacité
d'oxydation alors c'est ces roches
ophiolitiqu péridotiqu on les retrouve
euh en dans les apnins on retrouve au
nord de de l'Italie par exemple on en
retrouve en à Chypre en Turquie en
Grèce donc dans les Philippines on
retrouve dans différents endroits de la
planète parce que si maintenant on a
comme guide de de chercher des massifs
opiolitiques
et bien euh mais qui soit dans une
condition de d'oxydoréduction dans un
niveau d'oxydoréduction intéressant on a
là un guide de prospection géologique et
puis on retrouve il y a une deuxième
option donc j'ai dit qu'il y avait deux
options ça c'est la première et la
deuxième ce sont finalement les des
roches très anciennes qui se retrouvent
au centre des grandes plaque
continentale alors là il y en a par
exemple en Russie il y en a euh par
exemple aux aux États-Unis euh dans le
CAN SAS euh c'est c'est c'est connu il y
a des occurrences de production
d'hydrogène alors selon les cas dans
dans les les deux options d'ailleurs que
ça soit des massifs ophiolitiques euh
euh et qui peuvent se transformer sous
l'action de l'eau euh par un un
processus qui est assez joli qui
s'appelle la serpentinisation donc voilà
et donc euh euh dans les deux options
finalement euh cet hydrogène selon les
cas va être massif c'est 90 % de la
production ça sera de l'hydrogène pur ou
ou beaucoup plus dilué tout tout dépend
un peu des des systèmes naturels la
nature n'est pas totalement encore sous
sous contrôle de l'humain
donc voilà les les les deux les deux
occurrences possibles mais qui fait que
finalement on a été amené nous à
découvrir sous avec ces guides de
prospection
géologique de découvrir par exemple des
localisations de production d'hydrogène
en Caroline aux États-Unis qui n'était
pas connu mais avec une approche de type
naturaliste et géologique et bien on
arrive à à démontrer que dans certains
endroits il devrait y avoir des
productions d'hydrogène et on en observe
alors il y en a aussi en Afrique il y en
a notamment au Mali
donc c'est un endroit un peu compliqué
en ce moment pour aller faire de la
prospection géologique mais donc il y a
il y a une diversité il y a une
diversité de d'endroits sur la planète
où on observe une une production
d'hydrogène et le le plus souvent donc
une une hypothèse de de mécanisme c'est
celui dont que j'ai décrit qui est ce ce
mécanisme de
d'oxydoréduction alors pour les les les
les roches très anciennes qui se situent
au cœur des des plaques continentales
dans des parties où la croûte terrestre
est amincie où elle où il y a des
failles possibles qui mettent en
relation les les couches profondes de de
la croûte avec la surface il peut y
avoir aussi d'autres mécanismes qui qui
se produisent on est dans des conditions
de température de pression qui sont
importantes et on peut avoir des des
mécanismes type électrolyse mais ça ça
reste ça
reste un objet de recherche alors j'ai
parlé pour les évents situés dans les
rides médio-océaniques de de quantité
assez
importante de de production d'hydrogène
pour ce qui concerne
les ce qu'on peut observer onshore enfin
disons sur le continent euh là on est
sur des productions d'hydrogène qu'on a
observé de façon beaucoup plus modeste
on est de l'ordre de 5 à 10000 m³ cube
par jour voilà mais le le souci de de
ces de production d'hydrogène c'est que
et bien l'hydrogène n'est pas produit
par une seule fissure et puis il
suffirait de mettre un ballon au-dessus
et de récupérer l'hydrogène donc on a on
a un système finalement de de filuration
qui existe et qui est toujours corrélé à
la production d'hydrogène parce que
finalement il y a une transformation de
la roche et qui dit transformation de la
roche dit éventuellement consommation et
et modification du du volume de la roche
donc effondrement en profondeur qui se
traduit en surface par des sortes de de
cratères même si c'est pas
nécessairement lié à des systèmes
volcaniques et donc on a on a
nécessairement un cortège de de de
failles de de fracture de fissur et
finalement l'hydrogène qui a été mis à
la surface il est émis de façon un peu
disséminée donc euh il faut euh car
caractérisé un peu en profondeur comment
ce cette production d'hydrogène se se
produit est-ce qu'on a une capacité à
venir collecter en profondeur cet
hydrogène vous voyez là à tout un
chantier de de Red donc pour
résumer production d'hydrogène naturel
oui même donc connu depuis longtemps
maintenant des guides des guides de de
de prospection géologique qui se
clarifient progressivement et qui ont
amené à faire des des découvertes de de
de production naturelle d'hydrogène sur
les continent euh mais aussi on parlait
de de de système isolés par exemple en
Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a aussi tout à
fait de la production d'hydrogène donc
au large de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie euh et donc on a on a
là maintenant des des clés pour pour
identifier des des lieux possibles de de
production d'hydrogène j'ai parlé un peu
de la France surtout dans pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour ce qui concerne
le la France métropolitaine on pourrait
dire
euh il y a quelques occurrences de
production d'hydrogène notamment dans le
bassin du Sud-Est de la France mais qui
qui reste modeste et qu' faut dont il
faut comprendre mieux les l'origine
géologique alors les les les coûts de
production d'un hydro gène naturel on n'
est pas là il faudrait déjà quantifier
les choses voir s'il y a possibilité de
développer des modes de production de
type pétrolière ou gazière donc on n est
pas là on en est encore à qualifier le
la la la forme sous laquelle cet
hydrogène est est émis et voir si on
peut proposer des moyens ensuite de
collecte industrielle par des puits de
de cet hydrogène al après au-delà de ça
d'cun imagine que on pourrait proposer
des systèmes mimétiqu enfin des systèmes
industriels qui viendraient mimer ce que
la la nature sait faire pour pas cher on
parlait de coût de séparation de de
l'hydrogène d'autres constituants bah là
la nature travaille gratuitement pour
pour
nous est-ce que industriellement il y
aurait lieu de de proposer des des
système qui viendrait travailler sur des
procédés d'oxydoréduction bon je je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas du
tout dans des niveaux économiques mais
certains laboratoires commencent à s'y
intéresser voilà je vous
remercie très bien merci je vous propose
peut-être que le débat on l'enclenche
après avoir entendu les quatre
intervenants de la deuxième table ronde
si ça vous convient chacun garde à
l'esprit la possibilité qu'il y a dans
ce domaine merci donc monsieur
kalaijan pour cet exposé passionnant qui
démontre encore une fois que nous
disposons dans notre pays de de
compétences scientifique et technique
qui sont quand même considérables sur le
sujet et qui se profilent je vais
maintenant me tourner plutôt vers
monsieur
Arthur
mofacami que j'avais presque interpellé
tout à l'heure excusez-moi directeur
technique de la société Sam ID qui va
nous parler de moyen beaucoup plus bas
banal pour obtenir de l'hydrogène un
moyen qui est connu hein puisque il
s'agit de l'électrolyse de l'eau c'est
un procédé qui a été mis en œuvre pour
la première fois aux environs des années
1800 donc c'est pas tout à fait d'IER il
pourrait permettre d'utiliser
l'électricité excédentaire notamment
d'origine renouvelable bien entendu pour
produire de l'hydrogène toutefois
l'hydrogène ainsi produit reste à ce
jour beaucoup plus coûteux que celui
obtenu à partir
d'hydrocarbures notamment à partir de
gaz naturel de méthane voire de biogaz
est-il possible d'améliorer le rendement
des électrolyseurs tout en les rendant
plus accessibles en un mot sera-il
possible demain de produire avec de
l'électrolyse de l'hydrogène à moindre
coût monsieur
mofai pourra peut-être répondre à ces
questions en tout cas c'est les
interrogations qu'on lui pose de manière
à pouvoir envisager de nouvelles voies
de positionnement de l'hydrogène sur
notre territoire je vous donne la parole
merci beaucoup de m'avoir donné la
parole et surtout de donner la parole à
camide
euh donc peut-être que on va pouvoir
déconstruire un autre mythe mais en tout
cas on va on va y voir plus clair
j'espère à la fin de de mon exposé
euh donc deux mots quand même sur la
société ceramide euh créé en 2005 euh
suite là je dois euh tirer mon chapeau
aux aide publique suite à au de prix
successifs de l'innovation de Z envar
qui nous a vraiment permis de de lever
des fonds derrière euh la société a mis
en place à créé euh une nouvelle
membrane é changeurionique ce qui euh a
permis de développer des prototypes et
des applications diverses
variées et aujourd'hui il y a un pilote
industriel qui permet la production de
cette membrane et une des applications
de la membrane est bien sûr la
production d'hydrogène par électrolyse
euh donc
euh pour justement aborder le le sujet
de de production d'hydrogène par
électrolyse il faut d'abord essayer de
voir quelles sont les différentes
technologies qui existent sur le
marché
euh il est qui sur le marché qui sont
disponibles en fait sur le marché qui
sont pas à l'état de recherche euh les
deux technologies euh dont on peut citer
c'est l'électr la technologie alcaline
et la technologie PEM qui est plutôt des
électrolytes acides
euh bon comme vous l'avez remarqué la
technologie alcaline existe depuis 1900
euh en
1939 une unité de 10000 normau mè cube a
été a été été créé
et et plus tard en
1959 je crois l'urg a fait une première
un premier électrolyseur de de 30
barres après bon de quelle manière c'est
c'est des choses sur lesquelles on va y
arriver mais la technologie alcaline est
une technologie vraiment mature avec on
connaît bien ses limites et on connaît
bien ses capacités ses
capabilités on peut par exemple
aujourd'hui citer les les les les les
sociétés les plus actifes dans ce dans
ces technologiel qui sont hydrogénixes
euh société européen et canadien qui qui
propose des des unités d'électrolyse
alcaline à travers le monde et pas mal
installé en en Allemagne pour justement
le power to gas euh en posité Nil euh
qui est une émanation de Statoil euh
norvégien et qui propose aussi des des
excusez-moi des électrolyseurs
alcalins de plus faible de plus
faible disons capacité et Enertrag qui a
été dernièrement racheté par mcfi
société française et il va peut-être en
parler cet après-midi et qui au
contraire réalise des électrolyseurs de
2 à 6 MW enfin des unités en tout cas de
stack de 2 MW mais quand on regarde
publication de euh de ces de ces
sociétés actu actuellement sur le actif
et sur le
marché la le rendement de cette
technologie est quand même de l'ordre de
58 à 60 %.
euh alors ça c'est on peut le voir j'ai
les sources sont sur sur internet par
exemple nertrag dit que à 1000 normomè³h
la consommation électrique est de 6 MW
eu quand on fait le calcul simple on
tombe sur 58 % de rendement et donc ça
c'est un un aspect euh qui qui est un
peu euh amélioré dans le cadre des des
technologies
alcalines l'autre aspect c'est la
pression donc on a beaucoup parlé de la
pression par rapport à stockage
d'hydrogène et aujourd'hui
euh la majeure partie des électrolteurs
de puissance alcaline je parle pas des
petites électr éoliseur mais de
puissance fonctionne à à pression
atmosphérique euh et derrière il y a un
surpresseur ou compresseur qui permet de
monter à 30 bares ou
davantage ça aussi c'est un autre aspect
à améliorer et quelle est la raison
c'est-à-dire une technologie qui est qui
est mature pour quelle raison elle a pas
réussi à avoir des électrolyseurs qui
sont sous pression en en réalité il faut
il faut aller un peu plus en détail dans
la technologie la technologie alcinee ne
possède pas de membrane échangeuse
ionique en fait on utilise des
séparateurs comme à l'origine c'était
des séparateurs en en aspestos
excusez-moi le mot français amiante
merci merci beaucoup et et maintenant
qui sont interdites en utilisation et et
maintenant on utilise plutôt des
membranes fourni par
acha mais mais mais mais ça ça empêche
la la la la montée en pression parce
qu'il y a un mixage de gaz qui peut se
produire à travers ces ces séparateurs
qui sont micrerforé et aussi ça empêche
d'augmenter la la le rendement parce que
il faudrait rapprocher les les les
électrodes de de cette séparateur ce qui
ce qui générait encore une fois un
problème de de mélange de gaz produit
Ensemble bon il y a des recherches qui
sont engagées pour améliorer ça
notamment hydrogen X dans un consortium
à accès à des fonds européens pour
pouvoir trouver des solutions par
rapport à C problématique
mais voilà voilà l'état de de la
technologie
alcaline maintenant où est-ce qu'on en
est sur la technologie PEM
elle aussi ce n'est pas une technologie
nouvelle en fait PEM premier
électrolyiseur PM date de 1966 l'anné où
je suis né donc on a le même âge si vous
voulez et et et
depuis beaucoup de
beaucoup d'électro ont été développé en
PM mais toujours à petites échelles on a
jamais réussi et pourtant il y a des
sociétés qui ont essayé a essayé a
essayé c'est de sociétés les plus
grosses qui me vient à l'idée si
aujourd'hui SEV ai mais ils n'ont pas
réussi à supplentter la technologie
alcaline et pourtant les rendements sont
meilleurs on est de l'ordre de 80 % de
rendement
euh global au minimum à 75 % de
rendement avec l'ensemble du système qui
l'entoure
euh euh on a plus d'électrolytees on
consomme que de l'eau en fait c'est la
membrane qui contient euh disons la la
partie active pour transformer l'eau en
en ion et et en en ensuite permettre aux
électrodes de le transformer en gaz
hydrogène et oxygène et et donc je pense
alors ça j'ai pas de réponse à ça mais
je pense qu'il y a un problème
inhérent à cette technologie par rapport
à
l'électrolyse DUP DUP pon de nemour qui
est fabricant de d'une de ces membranes
pour PEM qui s'appelle le Nafion
à a sur son site un un document
technique sur sur le Nafion et tant que
vous utilisez le le Nafion dans le
domaine de pile à combustible bon il y a
pas trop de problème parce que
la membrane est très sensible aux ions
bivalents calcium magnésium alors après
d'autres ions comme le faire ont
la la
mauvaise euh habitude de se précipiter à
l'intérieur de la membrane sur les sites
actives et bloquer les sites actives de
sorte que dans la communication du Dupon
ils indiquent que la qualité de l'eau
utilisé devrait être inférieur à 20 ppb
pour le calcium et magnésium et un ppm
pour le faire et là on sort un problème
qui fait que les
électrolyseurs disons PM peuvent durer
longtemps mais il faut faire extrêmement
attention à la qualité de l'eau qu'on
leur fournit pour vous donner un chiffre
un nom de fonctionnement d'un
électrodiseur PM à 1 MW 200 normomè cube
va à à à une qualité d'eau de 5 ppm
pardon 5 ppm 5 micro donc 2,5 ppm
d'impureté va engendrer une accumulation
de 4 kg de ces ions là à l'intérieur des
stacks et donc ça inévitablement ça va
diminuer l'efficacité donc on va passer
de 80 % d'efficacité à 60 voire 50 %
d'efficacité donc ça c'est un des
problèmes qui ont qui a peut-être été à
l'origine de de de de de cette
stagnation technologique
aussi mais bon malgré tout il y a a des
gens qui proposent aujourd'hui des
électrolyseurs de 1 MW dans ces
technologie là bon toujours faut-il
faire attention à l'eau si on fait
attention à ça au niveau maintenance et
durabilité on peut y arriver il y a des
électros qui ont fonctionné dans les
sous-marins de plus de 40000 he je crois
ou davantage encore mais là encore une
fois il faut faire très attention à la
qualité de
l'eau et donc nous est-ce qu'on a fait
au sein de céramide on a mis au point
une membrane qui échangeuse unique mais
qui contient pas d'acide fort à
l'intérieur de la membrane mais que une
acide faible et cet acide faible n'a pas
du tout euh de d'affinité avec les
iombivalents d'ailleurs ces iombivalents
sont conduites dans cet acide faible
aussi dans ce dans ce milieu électrolyte
solide et alors pour produire la
l'hydrogène enfin les lesésons
nécessaires on rajoute 10 % d'acide
sulphurique et 10 % d' sulfurique dans
le milieu industriel c'est pas quelque
chose de compliqué à gérer il y a il y a
bien d'autres électrolyseur pour
d'autres applications où l'acidité est
beaucoup plus importante donc on a
réussi à mettre au point
des des des deux prototypes un de ces
prototypes là a été testé sur un site
industriel pendant un an et demi et qui
nous a permis de faire le deuxème
prototype qui est qui va être livré à
rve en Allemagne pour les essais en
power to gas c'est un prototype de 30
normomè cubeur d'ailleurs on serait très
intéressé de rit cette expérience en
France avec des partenaires français sur
des électrolyseurs qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 300 normomè cubeh c'està dire on
parle de 1,4 MW en
fait on a réussi à
mettre à concevoir un électrolyseur
modulaire on fait des unités de 15
normomè cubeh qui sont toutes les pièces
sont industrialisées donc une réduction
de coût importante la membrane est
fabriqué en France par nous-même et et
et ça permet de réduire considérablement
le coût du du cœur de de la technologie
l'équivalent de de de stack pil
combustible qui est en électrolyse et
après on les assemble sous forme de
modulle c'est quelque chose qu'on a
brofeté donc c'est des modules de qu
stack et ces modules peuvent se
s'interconncter jusqu'à 5 modules ce qui
vous fait
20 20 STAC chacun produitisant 15 normè
cubeur et ça vous fait 300 nmomè cube
donc 1,4 MW à un rendement de 76 %
pardon
et et donc quand on fait l'étude de coût
d'hydrogène produit par ce genre de
système comme je vous l'ai déjà dit
ce dans notre cas 80 % du cût de
l'hydrogène produit vient
d'électricité une simulation avec
l'élecité à 60 € le mgawh donc en France
quelque chose qui se pratique en France
nous amène à un coût de 4 € le kilogam
d'hydrogène prenant en compte la chat de
la du système en prenant en compte la
maintenance la consommation de l'eau
enfin tout ce qui tout ce qui va avec et
maintenant si on on imagine que on a
accès à une électricité détaxé ou en
tout cas moins cher ou en tout cas
peut-être l'cité qui est perdue ou ou
qu'on gagnerit en ne pas modifiant la la
la quantité de production je parle de
nucléaire par exemple où on est obligé
de moduler ou alors l'énergie
renouvelable excédentaire là là on peut
avoir une moyenne de euh de coût
d'électricité de 20 € le mgaw par
exemple et là on est équivalent au prix
de gaz naturel à l'achat pas à la
revente à l'achat donc le prix de
l'hydrogène est très très dépendant de
la source d'électricité auquel on a
accès ou pas et ça c'est aussi peut-être
je dirais pas une décision politique
mais une décision en tout cas
industrielle en France pour euh aller
dans ce sens ou pas voilà j'ai j'espère
que je j'ai j'ai réussi à à décortiquer
un peu le myth de l'hydrogène cher mais
voilà merci
beaucoup très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur
mofacami pour cette présentation et
cette orientation que que vous nous
donnez une fois que l'hydrogène a été
produit au prix le plus bas possible
puisque c'est bien de cela quand même
dont il s'agit il est généralement pas
consommé de suite il faut donc le le
stocker et le stocker d'une façon sûr
avec un coût final qui soit lui aussi
acceptable pour le consommateur et c'est
Monsieur Jérôme Goset qui est directeur
de la Business uni
stockage d'énergie
d'Areva qui va nous en dire de mots
puisqueil est un petit peu le
spécialiste de l'art dans ce dans ce
domaine là et nous savons que c'est un
goû boulot d'étranglement
important dans la filière hydrogène que
celui du stockage monsieur boss vous
avez la parole monsieur le sénateur
pasteor merci de me donner l'occasion de
prendre la parole dans cette audition
pour mettre en perspective la la
problématique du stockage de l'hydrogène
je voudrais commencer par dire que le le
stockage de l'énergie est au cœur des on
sait bien des la gestion de l'énergie
intelligente et parmi les différentes
technologies de stockage l'hydrogène
présente la caractéristique particulière
d'être extrêmement flexible
d'offrir une multi une multiplicité
d'usage possible qu'on a pu apercevoir
ce matin dans les dans la table ronde on
peut refaire du kilwh avec des piles à
partir de l'hydrogène que ce soit dans
les applications stationnaires Nomad
industrielles ou tercière on peut grâce
à ces piles grâce au stockage de
l'énergie permis par les électrolyseurs
aussi gérer l'énergie intermittente sur
un réseau électrique donc produire des
services réseau on peut utiliser ce gaz
hydro qui aura été produit directement
sous forme de gaz pour utiliser sa
chaleur dans le power to gaz dont on
parlera après et puis évidemment en a
longuement parlé on peut l'utiliser en
mobilité comme un carburant que ce soit
pour la mobilité routière ou plus
largement d'autres types comme les
bateaux des appareils un peu
particuliers cette multiplicité d'usage
possible rencontre en fait une
multiplicité de de questions ou d'enjeux
qui qui existent au niveau au niveau des
territoires alors je pas c'est pas à
vous que je vous apprendrai quels sont
ces enjeux mais peut-être pour les
illustrer rapidement il y a
l'attractivité d'un territoire en terme
industriel ou d'activité agricole donc
sur l'accès à une énergie fiable et pas
cher il y a la gestion locale des
réseaux de distribution que ce soit de
gaz ou d'électricité AC la question de
la production locale d'énergie et
peut-être demain celle de
l'autoconsommation il y a la question
des bâtiments de l'amélioration de le
performance énergétique de les rendre
autonomes à l'échelle donc d'un bâtiment
voir d'un quartier et puis toutes les
questions liées autour de de l'accès à
l'énergie de la de la précarité
énergétique donc tous ces sujetsl en
fait sont aujourd'hui bousculés ou en
tout cas renouvelés par les évolutions
du monde de l'énergie et en fait ça
amène à s'interroger sur l'émergence de
ce que je peux appeler des circuits
énergétiques courts ou des moyens de
produire localement de l'énergie et de
la gérer et pour cela il y a
impérativement besoin de stockage et
donc la question qui se pose c'est ça
effectivement du déploiement possible de
ces de ces filières courtes et qu'elles
peuvent être leur part finalement dans
dans le mix énergétique global par
rapport à la solution classique qui
consistait à aller acheter cette énergie
loin que soit l'énergie électrique produ
dans des centrales au travers d'un
réseau électrique soit l'énergie gaz qui
viendrait de gisement divers et variés
par des pipelines ou du pétrole donc on
est dans un changement de paradigme
assez fort et qui impose effectivement
de de stocker de stocker de l'énergie et
la gérer au mieux
possible donc l'hydrogène c'est bien une
technologie qui va accompagner cette
transition énerg égétique vers plus de
plus de modèles énergétiqu de circuit
court et et je pense qu'effectivement le
le le les différents moyens de
stockageénergie permettent par les
différents moyens de stockage hydrogène
permettent d'imaginer des chaînes
énergétique courte qui utilisent cet
hydrogène à des échelles
différentes ça peut aller alors je je
parlerai pas des applications nobat je
connais très mal mais si on est sur du
système de secours une antenne relais on
va avoir besoin de quelques jours
d'autonomie à 5 kW donc on va parler
d'une vingtaine de kilos d'hydrogène si
on est sur un bâtiment
euh tertière ou publ on peut être à
l'échelle de 50 kW où là on aura besoin
typiquement d'une journée d'autonomie on
va parler là de 70 kg d'hydrogène si on
est sur une plateforme raccordée au
réseau électrique comme myt en Corse où
là on a 200 kW de pile 200 kW
d'électrolyse euh et qu'on veut une
autonomie à peu près d'une journée on
est là sur 150 kg d'hydrogène et puis si
on on parle vers dans le on garde vers
le futur dans des applications
typiquement power to gaz on va avoir des
électrolyseurs qu'on va probablement
mettre en série pour faire mettons
prenons un chiffre 100 MW d'électrolyse
sur
lequel on va produire à longueur de
journée ou par des enfinons par dizaine
d'heur ça peut représenter 70 tonnes
d'hydrogène par jour produite donc on
voit bien que là la mise en œuvre
d'hydogène à différentes échelles
implique des des échelles qui qui sont
très variées et donc qui demandent une
diversité de moyen de stockage
euh pour pouvoir être mis en œuvre alors
si je les balaye et que j'enresse un un
panorama rapide euh on peut peut-être
donc on pense
évidemment en tout premier on peut
penser à l'hydrogène liquide qui est
bien connu qui qui est qui est bien mis
en œuvre sur le plan industriel qui a la
partti la l'avantage d'avoir des très
fortes densités énergétiques mais qui
est très coûteux à produire parce qu'il
faut descendre la température très bas
et qu'il a une autoconsommation
énergétique très forte puisqu'il faut
maintenir cette température basse donc
c'est c'est une technologie qui est
réservée à des usages avancés et qui
n'est pas très adapté à à l'hydrogène
énergie donc on peut on peut l'oublier
pour ce qui nous concerne on a parlé
tout à l'heure du stockage gaz sous
pression alors effectivement c'est une
technologie qui est bien éprouvé qui
aujourd'hui on peut trouver on peut
stocker de l'hydrogène jusqu'à 200
barres c'est c'est très courant ça peut
se faire donc ce qu'on appelle l'enderac
c'estàd des des paquets de bouteilles
qu'on peut entreposer déplacer avec des
ch élévateurs ou alors c'est carrément
une remorque de camion qui est composé
de de d'une dizaine de bouteilles mises
horizontalement et qui font la longueur
de la de la remorque on peut aussi avoir
et c'est ce qu'on a sur Myrt typiquement
en Corse des des gros réservoirs qui
ressemblent à au réservoir de propane ou
de méthane enfin de de gaz qu'on peut
avoir chez soi et qui permettent de
stocker l'hydrogène là sur myt en
l'occurrence on fait à 35 barres donc ça
c'est une technologie qui est bien
connue qui qui est extrêmement
performante mais qui est je dirais euh
qui qui qui qui qui n'évolue pas dire
qui qui qui est bien établi et qui bouge
pas euh il a été évqué tout à l'heure le
fait qu'effectivement depuis quelques
années le besoin pour la mobilité de
stockage à 350 ou 700 barres a amené un
certain nombre d'acteurs à faire des
travaux de développement et aujourd'hui
il y a une rupture technologique qui est
en train d'aboutir qui est celle des
réservoirs à 700 bares et donc
évidemment par de conséquence toute
pression inférieur à 700 bar et aussi
accessible donc c'est des des des
stockages en fibre de carbone revêtu
l'intérieur d'un revêtement étanche à
l'hydrogène et qui qui vont qui vont
permettre en fait euh deux choses
d'abord livré sur un site euh on peut
loger dans un volume très restreint une
une une quantité d'énergie très
importante qui va permettre en fait une
longue autonomie ce qui est extrêmement
important pour des sites isolés ou
difficiles d'accès quand on veut les
rendre autonome pendant un certain temps
et puis l'autre aspect important c'est
ce type de stockage va permettre de
multiplier par un facteur 4 à 5 la qu
quantité d'énergie embarqué sur un
camion de livraison d'hydrogène et donc
pour tout ce qui est hydrogène livré par
camion il y a là un une une rupture
forte sur le coût d'accès finalement à
de l'hydrogène qui serait produit de
façon centralisée qui serait délivré sur
un site deé donc ça c'est une innovation
importante qui a été d'ailleurs
supportée par la puissance publique en
France au travers d'zo dans le programme
H2 et qui est essentiellement mené par
Air Liquide et par et par composite
Aquitaine donc là c'est une rupture
importante mais c'est pas la seule on a
parlé aussi tout à l'heure des hydrures
ça c'est une deuxième rupture importante
qui qui là vise le stockage solide donc
là il s'agit de d'immobiliser
l'hydrogène dans un hydrure donc qui est
un matériau solide euh donc on fait ça
en fait en en injectant de l'hydrogène
autour de cette hydrure et et on le fait
sous pression et ça va faire rentrer les
entre guillemets le l'hydrogène dans
l'hydrure en libérant un peu de chaleur
qu'on peut ou pas récupérer en fonction
de en fonction de le de du du rendement
finalement enfin de la complicité qu'on
s'autorise sur l'installation et du
rendement qu'on souhaite l'avantage des
hydrures c'est de c'est de stabiliser
l'hydrogène parce que comme au moment du
stockage il y a un relargage de chaleur
finalement l'hydrogène se retrouve piégé
il y a plus assez d'énergie pour qu'il
ressorte et pour le faire ressortir
justement il falloir lui redonner cette
chaleur donc l'avantage de cette
solution c'est c'est ça sécurité c'est
la stabilisation de l'hydrogène qu'elle
apporte et le deuxième avantage c'est la
la très grande densité d'hydrogène qu'on
peut avoir par mètre cube on est dans
les hydrures à une centaine de grammes
d'hydrogène par mètre cube par
comparaison on est à 40 g dans des
stockages 40 g par m³ pardon dans des
stockages à 700 barres alors toute
technologie a ses inconvénients celle-ci
euh pose quelques problèmes sur la
cinétique c'està-dire la la dynamique de
ces systèmes là elle pose aussi des
questions des problèmes sur la la pureté
des gaz qu'elle peut qu'elle peut
accepter alors je mentionnerai aussi une
une autre technologie intéressante qui
est celle du stockage alors ça ressemble
aux hydrures mais en fait on va stocker
le mat l'hydrogène dans un une molécule
qui va rester liquide alors elle
s'appelle un nom barbare qui s'appelle
carbasol je vous donnerai pas la
formuleis bien incapable mais en fait
c'est une molécule dans lequelle on peut
charger jusqu'à une vingtaine voire 25
atomes d'hydrogène et qui a l'avantage
en fait d'être un un liquide qui va
avoir des propriétés très proches de
Cell du diesel à la fois en terme de
densité et de et de contenu énergétique
il y a 1,7 kWh d'énergie hydrogène qu'on
peut stocker dans chaque litre de ce de
ce composant donc c'est un liquide donc
qui pourra utiliser les mêmes
infrastructures que le diesel ce serait
ça son intérêt qui aurait toute la
praticité d'un d'un liquide pour la mise
en œuvre l'inconvénient là c'est un peu
comme pour les
hydrures le fait de pour stocker et
déstocker l'hydrogène de devoir passer
par des étapes de conversion qui mettent
en œure des température relativement
élevée donc une certaine relative
complexité de la du stockage et des
opérations de stockage et de dstockage
hydrogène alors le dernier la dernière
grande option qui qu'il faut mentionner
c'est celle du power to gaz alors c'est
pas pas tellement une technologie mais
c'est presque plus un concept qui
consiste en fait à à utiliser les
réseaux de gaz existants de façon à
injecter de
l'hydrogène pourquoi cette idée parce
que les réseaux de gaz représentent des
capacités de stockage très importante
euh le volume et la pression qu'on peut
injecter dans ces réseaux et la réserve
la marge de manœuvre entre la pression
moyenne d'exploitation et la pression
maximale que peuvent supporter ces
réseaux permettre d'envisager de stocker
de grande quantités de gaz on peut même
aller utiliser comme on fait pour le gaz
naturel des des des cavités ou des
structures géologiques dans lesquelles
on pourrait stocker cet hydrogène il y a
d'ailleurs une étude européenne en ce
qui a cour qui a lieu en ce moment qui
s'appelle I underer qui qui cherche à
faire l'évaluation et la comparaison des
différentes structures géologiques en
vue du stockage d'hydrogène donc il y a
des résultats provisoires qui sont
sortis je pense que les résultats
définitifs sont attendus dans le courant
l'année prochaine et en fait ce réseau
de gaz va être pour le stockage de
l'hydrogène ce qui est une montagne pour
le stockage d'énergie par hydraulique
finalement il y a là une réserve de
stockage qui est déjà investie déjà
payée et Don le coût marginal pour
l'exploiter pour l'hydrogène serait
relativement relativement faible alors
ça pose un de question je pense que GRT
reviendra dessus sur les aspects
sécurité ou le comportement finalement
du les problèmes que pose la variation
de la composition du gaz chez
l'utilisateur final alors on le voit là
on a un panorama finalement on a une
panoplie de solution de stockage qui
sont très variés qui peuvent être dans
des échelles adapté à ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure comme étant
tout ce qui a besoin toutes les échelles
auquelles on peut imaginer des des
système énergétique mettant en neuve
hydrogène
euh ce qui ce qui nous paraît important
pour la mise en œuvre de tout ça c'est
c'est c'est qu'aujourd'hui euh C ces
technouvelle et finalement cette
expérience ancienne permett d'imaginer
effectivement de gérer l'intermittence
et de gérer des flux énergétiqu nouveaux
des chaînes énergétiques nouvelles donc
des flux d'énergie qui qui qui qui
seraiit à mettre en place qui sont
nouveaux sur des sites isolés qui sont
avec la mobilité ou qui soit avec de
enfin en ayant en tête
l'autoconsommation et là l'hydrogène est
une bonne solution la difficulté c'est
de faire émerger ces chaînes finalement
pourquoi parce que elle demande de
mettre en œuvre d'un seul coup plusieurs
briques il faut à la fois avoir des
véhicules si on veut faire la mobilité
mais il faut aussi un électrolyseur il
faut un moyens de stockage il faut une
source d'énergie et il faut que tout ça
fonctionne dans un mod mod économique
alors peut-être aidé au début mais qui
doit être à terme viable et c'est c'est
l'émergence en fait de cet écosystème
qui est aujourd'hui complexe à mettre en
œuvre et qui a besoin je pense d'un d'un
support public les industriels
travaillent on l'entendu ce matin à
faire émerger les solutions à réduire
les coûts mais la mise en place et le
déploiement de ce genre de solution
demande à ce que la viabilité économique
et les modalités de mise en œuvre de ces
solutions soi étudié donc par exemple
étudier comment une région ou un une
collectivité donnée peut tirer parti de
ce type de scène de de énergétique ce
type de solution de de stockage de
l'énergie à à l'échelle de de ces
problématiques on pourrait imaginer de
sélectionner en France une dizaine de
projets de ce type là pour justement
passer aux actes et mettre en œuvre ce
type de modèle pour explorer leur
viabilité économique explorer comment
mettre sur pied des schémas des schémas
de de circulation de l'énergie et de
circulation des des revenus dans à un
niveau
local ce qui concerne la mobilité
évidemment il faut aussi regarder ça du
point de vue national et là il serait il
serait très intéressant que la la
puissance publique s'intéresse à à un
plan de mobilité hydrogène au niveau
national puisque les voitures ayant par
nature avec l'hydrogène une autonomie
très grande de l'ordre de 500 800 km
c'est évidemment pas au niveau
uniquement au niveau local qu'il faut
regarder la question de la mobilité
hydrogène et puis pour conclure je je je
rejoindrai les autres intervenants pour
insister sur les aspects la nécessité de
de de repenser un certain nombre de
points dans la réglementation donc sur
les aspects sécurité mise en œuvre
effectivement euh tout ce qui a été dit
sur les les les installations ICPE mais
aussi pour faire émerger un certain
nombre de de mécanismes de marché qui
vont permettre à des acteurs de de se
rémunérer et de et de et de et de faire
réellement vivre la filière hydrogène
donc je pense à la structuration des
marcher sur tout ce qui va être la
stabilisation des réseaux électriques
les services au réseau tout ce qui va
être la
mobilité le power to gaz aussi il faut
faut établir un cadre juridique qui
permet de faire fonctionner monsieur
évoqué tout à l'heure les les les
nécessités enfin les besoins aussi en
terme de réglementation du point pour
les applications nomades à ça
j'ajouterai effectivement aussi tous les
régimes fiscaux qui qui vont avec avec
la mise en uvre de ces nouveaux système
et également peut-être une réflexion à
avoir sur les tarifs auquels des tarifs
d'le ricité auquel on pourrait accéder
enfin faire accéder la technologie
d'électrolyse puisqu'on l'a vu c'est un
élément clé de la la rentabilité de la
de de la production d'hydrogène et de
son de son économie par électrolyse donc
la question du d'un tarif d'achat ou
d'un tarif auquel le le kilwh pourra
être accessible à la filière hydrogène
mériterait certainement réflexion voilà
je vous remercie de votre
attention très bien merci merci monsieur
gosé pour sur tour d'horizon et dans
votre dernier propos vous faites le lien
avec l'intervention de des représentant
de grtgas
euh vous avez utilisé le mot qui est de
pouvoir mettre en musique toute une
opération qui ferait que on aurait on
pourrait utiliser éventuellement les
réseau de de gaz et je préfère utiliser
ces propos-là puceque dans la note qu'
avait préparé je vois écrit le Power
toogas vous avez senti ma facilité à
parler l'anglais hein euh et mais bon
c'est comme ça
donc en contrepartie euh vous allez nous
nous éclairer et sans plus tarder je
vais donner la parole donc aux
représentants nous avons eu l'occasion
de de rencontrer euh un certain nombre
de collègues outrein en Allemagne sur ce
type de sur ce type de sujet et dans
l'après-midi nous on un représentant qui
viendra également nous en nous en parler
ils ont mis en place toute une opération
d'expérimentation avec la société Eon
notamment hein euh donc on a pu toucher
du doigt ce que cela pouvait représenter
et sans plus tarder je vais donner la
parole à Madame milè Poitou et à
Monsieur Patrick PEL pour nous faire un
tour d'horizon sur cette capacité qu'il
y a aussi à utiliser un réseau qui
existe un réseau qui est bien maillé sur
la totalité de notre territoire voir
comment et dans quelles conditions cela
pourrait apporter sa participation au
développement de l'hydrogène vous avez
la parole merci bien monsieur le
sénateur je voulais effectivement
rappeler un peu la spécificité du
système gazier qui permet justement les
applications dont on va parler tout à
l'heure
euh je voulais simplement rappeler que
c'était un véritable vecteur énergétique
de masse aussi euh puisque je vous
rappellerai tout
simplement les débits de pointe de
l'hiver 2012 qui a été assez
froid sur le réseau gazier il y a eu un
appel de puissance de l'ordre de 158000
mgaw alors que sur le réseau électrique
il n été seulement de 101000 MW c'estàd
presque plus que 50 % de plus en gaz
qu'en
électricité je voulais aussi rappeler
que c'était un transport à grande
distance puisque c'est un transport qui
qui je dirais sillonne sillonne toute
l'Europe et même au-delà jusqu'à aux
extrémités de
l'Asie et en France c'est à peu près
32000 km de canalisation dans lesquels
bien sûr nous nous avons une capacité
d'utilisation et je signalerai aussi que
c'est un transport à grande distance
mais à faible consommation puisque
l'autoconsommation de ce réseau n'est
que de 03 % de des quantités d'énergie
transporté enfin je signalerai que c'est
aussi une capacité de stockage bon bien
sûr de façon un petit peu journalière
dans le réseau de gazoduc mais surtout
il donne accès à un réseau de stockage
géologique il y en a 14 en France euh
qui peuvent représenter 25 à 30 % de la
consommation française euh en une année
donc on a vraiment une grande capacité
de stockage grâce à à l'accès à ce
réseau euh et là aussiù un point que je
voulais signaler c'est que mon voisin a
parlé de changement de paradigme et
c'est exactement ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre dans notre
activité qui est quand même assez
ancienne malgré tout qui a plusieurs
décennies d'existence le changement de
paradigme est le suivant c'est que nous
avons une orientation stratégique forte
pour accueillir des gaz
renouvelables les études que nous avons
fait montre que d'ici
2050 les possibilités le de gaz
renouvelable en France quand on combine
la méthanisation des déchets la
gazification de la biomasse
forestière évidemment aussi ce qu'on
appelle le power to gas c'est la
transformation d'électricité en
hydrogène recombiné ou non d'ailleurs
avec du gaz carbonique pour faire du
méthane donc du méthane de synthèse et
bien nous arrivons à un potentiel de
l'ordre de 220 tawh à comparé à la
consommation actuelle de la France qui
est inférieure à TWh donc on a déjà on
est à peu près de l'ordre de grandeur
actuel de la de la moitié de la
consommation française on sait que les
les consommations vont diminuer
plusieurs inter intervenant l'ont cité
il y a beaucoup d'efforts en terme
d'efficacité énergétique et donc ça veut
dire qu'à terme il est possible que le
le gaz naturel importé ait une
proportion de plus en plus faible dans
nos réseaux et donc une proportion de
gaz renouvelable de plus en plus
importante sur cette sur la proportion
d'hydrogène ou de de de enfin
d'hydrogène issu de d'énergie électrique
renouvelable menne on parlera tout à
l'heure mais effectivement c'est pas la
proportion la plus importante dans ces
gaz renouvelables on l'estime à peu près
à 10 % peut-être un peu plus peut-être
un peu moins mais et puis et puis après
l'avenir c'est difficile de le prévoir
l'essentiel c'est de le rendre possible
et c'est pour ça que nous essayons de
travailler sur ce sujetlà qui pour nous
est une voie d'avenir et une voie
d'avenir qui permet l'interconnexion
entre les systèmes électriques et les
systèmes gaziers et euh et cette
transformation d'électricité en en
hydrogène va permettre de contribuer à
une meilleure flexibilité de tous ces
systèmes euh et et et nous nous y
préparons parce que nous passous allons
passer d'un système où nous avons à peu
près C ou six entrées aux frontières
une quinzaine d'entrées par les
stockages souterrain à peut-être
plusieurs centaines de points d'entrées
sur le réseau et ça demande des
réflexions de gestion intelligente des
réseaux ce qu'on appelle les smart grid
c'est un peu l'expression à la mode même
si c'est de l'anglais excusez-moi
monsieur le sénateur mais
c'est bien sûr mais effectivement ça va
nous demander de réfléchir de façon
différente à la gestion de ces réseaux
et nous nous préparons aussi et donc
voilà voilà l'introduction que je
voulais faire avant de passer la parole
donc à milen sur plus précisément ce
qu'on souhaite faire avec le power to
gaz avec la transformation d'électricité
en
hydrogène bonjour alors je vous apporter
la partie économique de l'histoire de
l'étude que l'on a fait en fait on a
abordé comme comme l'a dit Patrick P le
débat sur la transition énergétique avec
cette vision de transformation du réseau
de gaz pour pouvoir avoir davantage de
gaz R renouvelable d'abord et puis de
pouvoir permettre le développement en
quelque sorte des des énergies
électriques renouvelables intermittentes
en offrant le réseau de gaz pour pour
valoriser en fait les surplus d'énergie
électrique donc on a réalisé avec iCub
stratégie consultant deux étude
économique la première qui ne vous
concerne pas vraiment aujourd'hui mais
mais mais quand même sur la première
question c'était quel est le le coût à
quel coût on pourrait produire beaucoup
de gaz renouvelaable et on arrive en
conclusion simplement et je vous la
présenterai avec plaisir un peu plus
tard si ça vous intéresse mais on
arrivait à dire que parmi l'ensemble du
potentiel évoqué par Patrick P les 150
terw les plus compétitifs et 150 taw à
un horizon 2050 ça ferait un 40 % en
imaginant une baisse des consommations
de 1 % par an on arriverait à un 40 50 %
en fait du gaz consommé en France qui
pourrait être d'origine renouvelable
pour un surcût euh de moins de 20 %
disons de la facture de du du
consommateur final 20 % horizon 2050
donc en fait une augmentation de moins
de 1 % par an de la consommation du
consommateur final je referme la
parenthèse c'est pas l'objet mais
c'était l'étude économique sur les gaz
renouvelables dans leur ensemble et
l'autre étude qui sur laquelle j'ai
davantage m'attardé confi également à
cuub stratégie consultant c'était pour
répondre à la question bon on voit bien
le la la production d'hydrogène à partir
d'électricité devient de plus en plus
rentable mais est-ce qu'on pourrait
vraiment imaginer dans un sc Scario
favorable avec beaucoup de surplus
d'origine
électrique
une une modélisation qui permet de
penser qu'en 20050 on pourrait avoir une
rentabilité pour pour couvrir en fait la
France des électrolyseurs en nombre
suffisant pour pouvoir absorber les
surplus qui ne pourrait pas être absorbé
par d'autres moyens c'était vraiment la
question posée donc iube stratégie
consultant est partie de la vision Adem
2050 pour avoir un scénario à horizon
2050 crédible faisant référence versé au
débat et qui avait le bon goût aussi de
prévoir beaucoup de de production
d'énergie électrique renouvelable avec
70 GW de capacité installée d'éolien
offshore et onshore et 60 GW de capacité
installée de photovoltaïque et puis ils
ont réalisé une modélisation heure par
heure de la de la production du mix
énergétique avec avec ces quantités de
de de renouvelable et en supposant en
bandeau produit en bandau un nucléaire à
cet horizon restant en fait en comp
pensant finalement la la la la capacité
en supposant que la capacité nécessaire
était celle qui n'était pas avec la
production de de renouvelable non non la
production de renouvelableon entre 2030
et
2050 substitué entre le renouvelable et
le nucléaire et en partant de la
capacité installée à la vision 2030 de
laadem parce que laad était silencieuse
sur la capacité installée en nucléaire à
2050 on arriva àci à une vingtaine de GW
restant ce qui nous a paru cohérent
puisque ça paraît ça pourrait être une
prolongation des duré des centrales
nucléaires à à 50 ans et un PR c'était
surtout pas l'objet de l'étude mais
l'idée c'était d'avoir un mix
énergétique qui nous permettait ensuite
de calculer quel volume de surplu le
volume de surplu auquel on arrivait avec
ce nucléaire là en band d'au
l'hydraulique en band d'au et puis le
nucl l'éolien le photovoltaïque bah
modulant sur des bases de sur des
données historiques des données
historiques allemandes d'ailleurs parce
que les françaises étaient quand même
assez assez peu trop faible pour en
tirer quelque chose et puis une
modulation également de la consommation
alors consommation électrique vision
2050 également mais modulé sur la base
de l'hiver
2011 on arrive avec une modulisation
heure par heure à voir qu'il y aurait
avec ces hypothèses 75 tawh de surplu
électrique c'està-dire de l'électricité
dont on ne sait pas que faire 75 tawh
c'est 5 à 6000 he en fait de surplu de
production et puis en même temps on
arrivait aussi à la la modélisation
concluit aussi à 27 TWh de déficit
pendant 3 à 4000 he donc 27 taw de
déficit supposé compensé par par exemple
des centrales combiné gaz ça nous permet
c'est une bonne idée à cet horizon 2050
mais en tout cas 27 TWh de déficit 75
TWh de surplus ça donne des données qui
ne qui qui sont cohérentes en quelque
sorte qui permettaient de de d'assoir le
le scénario basé ensuite sur cette
modélisation heure par heure on a
regardé quel quel était les les la
fréquence des surplus et quelles étaient
leur durée dans le temps et là on arrive
à une donnée qui pour nous cherchant à
favoriser quand même l'injection dans la
production d'hydrogène dans un premier
temps puis l'injection dans les réseaux
mais pour la production d'hydrogène en
tout cas on arrivait à des surplus de de
de de longue durée c'est-à-dire de sur
une période de plus de 3 jours de 3
jours à une semaine correspondant à 26
TWh parmi les 75 TWh 26 terwh étaent
produit sur des durées de plus de 3
jours et une dizaine de taraw était
produit entre 2 et 3 jours euh si bien
que on arrivait à dire que évidemment
les surplus les plus fréquents sont ceux
de courte durée inférieur à 12h
mais il y en avait à peu près 300 dans
l'année il y a une petite dizaine de
surplu qui durent plus de 3 jours mais
en volume par contre de de en quantité
d'électricité produite et à valorisé on
arrive à 80 % en fait des du volume
produit sur des périodes de plus de 12
he et là ça nous intéressait
particulièrement parce que l'idée
c'était de se dire on va pas proposer la
production d'hydrogène avec tout le
volume de surplu d'électricité produit à
cet horizon 2050 mais par contre on
cherchait à voir du coup les les surplu
de moins de 12 he on se dit que les
batteries le système de batterie le
système de stockage il on électrique
courte durée va se développer on va
mettre ça dans les batteries ensuite on
arrive au surplu de de moyenne durée de
de de 24 he un peu plus d'une journée là
on a les les stations de pompage qui
vont permettre de pouvoir stocker cette
cette ce ce volume sur des sur sur plus
produit pendant une journée ou guerre
plus d'une journée en tout cas on a
regardé également avec Icube les régimes
de vent pour voir dans quelle proportion
on pouvait imaginer exporter ces surplu
d'origine électrique notamment vers
l'Allemagne et là on a regardé et on a
vu que même en ayant des régimes de vent
différents en fait il se trouve qu'on a
20 % du temps alors donné historiqu hein
de même mais 20 % du temps seulement où
les périodes de surproduction ne ne sont
pas ne sont pas corrélées en fait entre
la France et l'Allemagne du coup on
s'est dit bah pendant 20 % du temps où
on sera à cet horizon 2050 en surplu on
peut imaginer que l'Allemagne ne sera
pas en surplu et on exportera donc 15
terraw également bref et pour faire un
petit peu
court il nous reste il nous restait une
une trentaine de taraw que l'on ne peut
pas
envisager valoriser autrement en fait
que par une production d'hydrogène on on
a saturé l'ensemble des des systèmes de
stockage électrique courte durée y
compris les les les les stations de
pompage euh on a exporté ce qu'on
pouvait exporter il nous reste une
trentaine de tawh et on est parti en
fait de de ce chiffre pour pour pour
pour faire l'analyse économique
sous-entendu on pourrait imaginer en
valoriser bien plus évidemment on
pourrait imaginer que les stations
pompage ne se développe pas autant que
prévu et mettre davantage dans pour la
production d'hydrogène mais on est resté
sur ces 30 TWh après on s'est dit on va
être déjà raisonnable quand même donc on
n'imagine pas installer un électrolyseur
pour ne tourner que quelques heures par
an donc on a dit 5 les 5 terwurs les les
les les moins fréquents finalement bah
ceux-là on va les laisser de côté on
imagine lesolienne mis à la terre et
cette quantité là perdu il nous restait
25 TWh et avec ces 25 TWh ça
correspondait dans la modélisation enfin
ça correspond à 1000 électrolyseurs de
10 MW installés donc au point des points
intelligents sur le réseau électrique
pour pouvoir soulager le réseau
électrique éviter des raccordements ver
des des des des renforcements de réseau
électrique pour absorber ces surplus
électriques et puis et ou raccorder au
pied de de d'éolienne éventuellement si
si si nécessaire donc 1000
électrolyseurs 10 MW dans la
modélisation avec cette modélisation
horaire en supposant avoir écrité les 5
t voitures du dessus on tournait sur le
parc de 1000 électrolyseurs en moyenne à
2 heur par an euh et par an et avec un
coup de l'électricité alors que l'on a
calculé en résultat en fait en 10ant le
le coût de l'électricité de
l'électricité en surplu donc elle est
gratuite à l'origine on était parti
là-dessus finalement on s'est dit il y a
pas besoin qu'elle soit gratuite elle
peut être mais très peu cher quand même
et avec un un coûp de l'électricité donc
très peu cher on arrivait à un taux de
retour sur investissement de ce parc de
mil électrolyseur de de de 10 % une
valeur actualisée nette positive on
arrive à conclure que c'est cible alors
moyenant certaines conditions une
condition qui est la condition la plus
forte je pense c'est une réduction du du
du du coût des électrolyur évidemment
d'un facteur alors j'ai annoncé d'un
facteur 5 pour passer de 1500 € du du GW
installé à 300 € du
GW aujourd'hui avec les les les chiffres
annoncés maintenant par camide sur la
rentabilité avec un prix de
l'électricité à 20 € de mgawh finalement
on peut on peut imaginer avoir une
rentabilité avec un coout un peu plus et
en tournant à 20 € du mgaw donc voilà ça
paraît ça ça paraît on arrive en tout
cas et je vais pas vous présenter tous
les détails de l'étude mais l'étude
conclut avec une série d'hypothèses à
pouvoir valoriser l'hydrogène produit
injecté dans le réseau de gaz naturel
donc valorisé au prix du gaz naturel
d'aujourd'hui 25 € du mgawh on arrivait
avec cette hypothèse de diminution de cû
d'un facteur 4 à 5 a montré qu'on
pouvait mettre 1000 électrolyseurs de 10
MW
en pensant qu'il pouvait descendre enfin
que le coût pouvaitêtre diminué d'un
facteur 4 à 5 et ce facteur 4 à 5
d'ailleurs on l'avait trouvé pas
seulement comme résultat de calcul et
parce que ça nous arrangeait mais
c'était l'hypothèse de cûp prise par le
laboratoire NREL le laboratoire du
département
fédéral aux États-Unis du Département
fédéral de l'énergie et c'est une
hypothèse qui prennent aussi dans dans
dans le rapport sur le développement en
fait du du du power to gaz mais là c'est
aux États-Unis mais en en pensant que en
passant d'un marché de niche aujourd'hui
l'électrolyur est sur un marché de niche
avec les évolutions technologiques
notamment sur le
PEM c'est l'hypothèse qui est prise en
fait par le NRL de baisse des coûts à un
horizon
2050 l'injection d'hydrogène dans le
réseau alors l'étude on avait regardé
l'ensemble des valorisations possi de
l'hydrogène là aussi et on on s'est pas
attardé sur sur les évolutions possibles
des piles à combustible donc je voudrais
me fâcher avec personne ici ici euh nous
on pense qu'il y a de la place pour tout
le monde là l'étude montrait qu'on
pouvait envisager euh injecter
l'ensemble de cet hydrogène dans le
réseau de gaz et on a on était sur des
sur une teneur relativement haute quand
même admissible par le réseau de gaz
donc on envisage pouvoir absorber
davantage ou du moins tout cet hydrogène
mais avec en passant assez rapidement à
de la méthanation derrière c'est-à-dire
une combinaison de l'hydrogène avec du
gaz carbonique pour faire du méthane de
synthèse et là on a arrive des alors à
l'échelle du problème quasi infini en
fait la capacité de stockage infini de
de de cet hydrogène injecté dans le
réseau et en substitution évidemment à
du gaz fossile ce qui permet aussi de
d'avoir un gaz davantage renouvelable
mais l'idée c'était quand même de dire
on a aujourd'hui jusqu'à 6 %
en mélange avec le gaz naturel de façon
transparente enfin on on est en cours
d'étude pour regarder sur certains
clients industriels sensibles notamment
sur certaines applications si le 6 %
pourrait être la teneur maximale ou non
mais en tout cas pour une une une teneur
relativement faible mais importante vu
les quantités transitées dans le réseau
en terme d'hydrogène on pourrait
imaginer 4 à 5 % de d'hydrogène dans le
réseau sans sans souci particulier sous
réserve de confirmation sur sur
certaines utilisations du gaz naturel et
ensuite ensuite beaucoup plus et autant
qu'il le faudrait en imaginant donc
combiner avec du gaz carbonique pour et
de l'hydrogène pour pour pour produire
du méthane de synthèse euh cette étude
nous a permis déjà de nous convaincre
qu'il y avait un avenir possible pour
pour l'hydrogène et du coup on s'apprête
à lancer un projet d'injection
d'hydrogène d'un projet pilote alors
j'ai bien noté la proposition de cabide
d'appel à partenaire nous on en est à
peu près au même point également
d'ailleurs on voudrait lancer pour en
visant les premières injections à
horizon 2016 donc un projet qu'on lance
vraiment en phase de faisabilité
aujourd'hui avec un appel à partenaire
d'ailleurs sur sur l'injection
d'hydrogène et puis comme on pense
également que la suite pourrait être de
passer à de la méthanation sur un projet
pilote aussi de méthanation dans une
dans une deuxème phase donc voilà pour
nous l'intérêt principal he de cette
étude c'était bien de pouvoir montrer
qu'il y avait un vrai rôle pour le
réseau de gaz pour pour soulager le
réseau électrique en quelque sorte en
imaginant enfin dans un scénario avec un
fort développement d'énergie électrique
renouvelable on voit aussi en en
creusant qu'on arrive à avoir un une une
offre de service qui pourrait se
développer vers vers un vers vers les
stockages d'hydrogène pour le coup en
imaginant pouvoir écréter une production
d'hydrogène et une valorisation en
hydrogène mobilité avec un stockage
d'hydrogène pas trop massif une
utilisation d'un hydrogène provenant
aussi d'énergie électrique renouvelable
et du coup pas forcément très
maîtrisable et un écrêtement du stockage
d'hydrogène utilisé pour un hydrogène
mobilité par le réseau de gaz également
donc là on est persuadé que et c'est
pour ça qu'on est alors on a bien noté
les petites pics sur sur le le gaz
naturel véhicule tout à l'heure nous on
pense vraiment qu'il y a de la place
pour tout le monde et en mobilité
d'ailleurs avec un développement de gaz
naturel véhicule et un développement de
de l'hydrogène mobilité et puis pour
pour nous GRT gaz transporteur de gaz et
surtout ayant un un réseau de gaz
naturel déjà existant et on a le moyen
de le valoriser en travaillant avec
l'ensemble de la filière et mobilité au
sens large et hydrogène en particulier
pour aujourd'hui
très bien merci merci Monsieur PEL merci
Madame Poitou pour nous avoir traduit
avec beaucoup de passion euh un sujet
qui nous interpelle tous et qui montre
combien il y a dans ce domaineelà encore
des complémentarités à à rechercher je
je vous propose d'ouvrir pour un petit
instant le le le débat s'il y a des
questions à poser et tant pis je vais
commencer par me donner la parole si
vous Z d'accord je résiste pas au
plaisir de vous poser une question à
vous
monsieur pardon mofakami c'est ça j
arriverai avant la fin de la journée
vous verrez cette question elle m'a été
suscitée par les derniers propos de de
Madame Poitou qui parlait d'un
investissement de 1000 électrolyseurs
évoqués donc
avec une division par 4 du prix des
éectroliseur oui oui effectivement j'ai
bien entendu c'est bien de cel don il
s'agit que vous en pensez et ben moi je
suis ravi d'aboord et je pense que pas
que moi il y a de la place pour tous les
acteurs qui font des électrolyseurs je
pense qu'il y a Areva ennergie
renouvelable qui qui en fait aussi
c'estth en France et donc je pense qu'il
y a un terrain pour l'ensemble des
acteurs pour pour coopérer pour parce
que 1000 c'est beaucoup alors on parle
d'horizon 2030 50 aussi 2050 donc on a
un peu le temps ça fait environ une une
dizaine vingtaine d'électrolyseurs par
an il y a de quoi euh susciter de la
croissance pour l'ensemble des acteurs
français en tout cas et si on le fait
pas les étrangers le feront à à notre
place je pense que l'hydrogénx est à la
porte et en ce qui nous concerne et nous
toutes les pièces de puzzle sont prêts
c'est-à-dire que on a nos stacks qui
sont industrialisés nos modules qui sont
euh conçus et réalisés donc on attend le
top départ pour pour commencer à
produire voilà donc pour nous c'est
c'est c'est ça sera qu'un effet de ben
j'espère que il y a des investisseurs
dans la salle ou que des gens entendront
pour pouvoir parce que on a besoin
d'investissement ça c'est évident que on
peut on peut pas faire ce genre de
volume sans sans investissement
conséquent derrière il y en a peut-être
pas dans la salle mais c'est prévu je
c'est filmé que quelqu'un vous entende
quelque part merci que Dieu vous entende
monsieur compléter ce que disait
monsieur Mami effectivement il y a
d'autres acteurs en France qui qui
travaillent sur l'électrolyse PEM en
particulier donc au sein d'ara et chez
CTH j' dirais là aussi sur la PEM donc
la technologie était très bien écrite
tout à l'heure là aussi les technologies
arrive à maturité effectivement l'enjeu
pour la technologie PEM peut-être par
rapport aux autres c'est c'est de monter
en en puissance c'estd d'aller vers des
électr de plus forte puissance mais
toutes les études qu'on a pu faire à la
fois sur la montée en puissance des
machines et la monté en volume de
production montre que les les facteurs
de réduction qui sont recherchés sont
tout à fait accessibles et je dirais à
horizon relativement rapide d'ici
quelques années moyennant un volume
suffisant de pilote et d'installation
précurseur mais c'est des c'est des
c'est des domaines de coût qui sont qui
semblent tout à fait accessibles donc
qui viennent gérer corroborer les
perspectives que que grtgas a tracé ok
avez-vous des questions monsieur chauv
oui est-ce que les autres opérate de gaz
en Europe comme vous se pose les mêmes
questions je pense que oui est-ce qu'ils
ont fait des études similaires et est-ce
qu'on peut envisager une espèce de de
marché européen de de l'hydrogène stocké
dans les
tuyaux c'est délirant ou pas
oui tout à fait alors ce que je n'ai pas
mentionné parce que le temps était court
quand même c'est on partage ces idées
avec d'autres transporteurs européens au
niveau des transporteurs on a signé un
accord de coopération au printemps avec
quatre autres transporteurs les Suédois
les Néerlandais les
Belges les qui je n'ai pas dit euh les
Danois les Danois et il n'y a pas encore
les Allemands mais ils devrai nous
rejoindre bientôt mais pour le moment
ils n'y sont pas encore sur pour porter
une vision en fait d'un système gaz
décarboné horizon 2050 et avec trois
axes l'un étant le power to gaz le deuxè
le développement des gaz renouvelables
et le troème le gaz mobilité GNV et GNL
euh c'est et et euh il y a différentes
initiatives aussi au niveau européen et
cette fois avec un pilotage avec avec
une forte implication allemande
notamment une plateforme power to gaz
sur les le nord-ouest de l'Europe avec
un des des un développement d'initiative
en fait pour pour arriver à à une
maturité et euh pour arriver à
développer en fait la filière et et je
vais rebondir sur ce que vous disiez euh
on sait que les biogaz lors de leur
production représentent 50 % à peu près
de CO2 et en fait il y a une réduction
de C CO2 à 5 % possible en en
nourrissant les bactéries par hydrogène
donc là aussi c'est un autre gisement
d'électrolyseur renouvelable de
préférence ou décarboné nucléaire pour
permettre d'augmenter la capacité de
production des biogaz en fait je
voudrais juste compléter justement je
voulais simplement citer l'exemple de
d'une marque de voiture qui s'appelle
Audi qui est allemande dans le groupe
Volkswagen et qui a fait une initiative
récente qui était de dire à ses clients
ils ont construit bien sûr des véhicules
à gaz aussi ils ont fait ce choixlà et
il y a à peu près un millier de stations
à gaz station GNV en Allemagne et ils
ont dit à leurs clients bon actuellement
vous avez fait un choix euh au gaz qui
est moins pollant globalement pour la
planète mais dès demain on vous promet
du gaz renouvelable complètement
renouvelable et ce demain est arrivé
hier finalement puisque ils ont
construit une usine qu'ils ont mis en
service au mois de septembre euh qui euh
combine à la fois un méthaniseur
justement qui produit effectivement à
peu près 40 % de gaz carbonique en même
temps que du biométhane et ils ont mis à
côté un électrolyseur alimenté par les
les éoliennes de la mer du Nord et qui
fabriqueent de l'hydrogène et il sature
le méthaniseur avec de l'hydrogène ce
qu' fait que ils injejectent dans le
réseau du biogaz enfin du biométhane
exactement et du gaz de synthèse du
méthane de synthèse qui est le produit
du gaz carbonique et de l'hydrogène et
et ce qui est assez enfin leur système
marketing est assez intéressant c'est
que ils fournissent au conducteurs des
Audi A3 gtron une carte de crédit ils
peuvent prendre le gaz et bien sûr dans
les stations et chaque soir ils ont la
consommation de leur clients et ils
donnent la consigne à leur usine de
produire la même quantité de gaz
renouvelable pour le
lendemain un concept intéressant on est
dans un changement de paradigme là on a
eu l'occasion effectivement de se rendre
sur place là où on avait peut-être pas
tout le temps toutes les réponses c'est
sur le prix de revient là c'est
encore prix mais vous avez raison le
prix de le prix est très élevé et il est
il n'a rien à voir avec les prix de
l'énergie on ne peut pas utiliser ce
prix là pour pour pour pour l'utiliser
pour de l'énergie classique pour du
chauffage c'est pas possible par contre
eu ce qu' disent nous c'est ça une
valeur d'usage parce que nos clients ils
sont intéressés par avoir ce type de gaz
pour leur voiture mais eux leur modèle
leur business model c'est pas de de
faire du gaz leur business modèle c'est
de vendre des voitures donc il récupère
par une voiture qui fonctionne à
l'énergie renouvelable h c'est un démar
oui en plus oui c'est un début avec avec
un concept un petit peu différent de ce
que nous avons en France c'estàd que
tout ce qui est bio quelque chose en
France se vend moins cher pour justement
lui donner un certain attrait alors que
chez eux ce qui est bio quelque chose se
vend plus cher parce que ce qui est plus
cher est
meilleur en tout cas c'est le
costat d'autres questions monsieur
Ferrari oui je voulais pardon juste
faire une remarque par rapport à ce qui
a été dit sur le pour donner une vision
peut-être un peu différente vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de Smart Grid je
pense que c'est un concept de Smart
Energy grid qui est en train de se créer
c'estàd que c'est un niveau supérieur et
c'est important de dire que quand on
parle réseau énergétique en France on a
tendance à tout de suite penser réseau
électrique le fait de mettre le réseau
gaz en parallèle du réseau électrique
c'est déjà une deuxième vision il faut
pas oublier que aujourd'hui les
hydrocarbures qui servent à faire le
plein de nos véhicules c'est un troisème
réseau énergétique hein qui est qui est
un flux énergétique très important et
voilà c'est cette perspective que que je
voulais juste donner pour bien
comprendre qui avait une complémentarité
en fait entre les différents réseaux et
du partage euh donc du partage pour les
différents usages aussi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a tendance à à à
limiter l'usage des hydrocarbures pour
les véhicules et le gaz pour le pour les
usages résidentiels en fait on voit bien
que par ce genre d'usage enfin par ce
genre d'expérimentation pardon il y a
des mélanges qui se font même si
aujourd'hui on parle de sation gaz
plutôt en Angleterre je connais bien
aussi l'exemple italien malheureusement
on n pas de station gaz enfin ou très
peu en France pour les véhicules
très bien je pense que tout le monde va
dans le même sens tout à fait d'accord
est-ce que vous voyez des problèmes
réglementaires dans votre stratégie des
problèmes qui restent à
résoudre oui effectivement il y en a
encore puisque alors comme je disais
tout à l'heure aussi bon le fait que ça
soit ICPE c'est pas un souci pour nous
puisqu'on a l'habitude de traiter ce
genre d'installation mais néanmoins si
c'était plus simple ça serait mieux
c'est vrai euh néanmoins le problème
réglementaire qu'on qu'on aura à gérer
sur cette affaire là c'est c'est sur la
la proportion d'hydrogène à accepter
dans le réseau donc c'est pour ça qu'on
actuellement on a une référence
réglementaire qui est pas qui est pas
forcément définitive qui nous permet
d'injecter jusqu'à 6 % mais bon nous on
préfère être prudent on préfère
étudier en profondeur et on verra après
quelle quelle limite réglementaire on on
discutera avec avec les autorités hein
parce que on est un opérateur prudent on
veut pas non plus
faire des expérimentations sans sans
garantie quand même donc effectivement
il y aura cet aspect là à à gérer ça
fait partie du projet hydrogène que nous
démarrons en ce moment et si vous faites
un hub énergétique européen est-ce que
vous avez des contraintes
d'interconnexion particulières qui
ferait que vous devriez tous par exemple
être au même niveau avec les mêmes modes
de fonctionnement ou Pasi oui alors
c'est vous avez raison on a déjà déjà
ces contraintes de qualité du gaz qui
existe qui sont des contraintes enfin
des contraintes des normes je dirais des
normes d'acceptation aux frontières et
qui sont harmonisé au niveau européen
l'hydrogène en fait
partie et c'est aussi sur ce point-là
qu'il faudra agir quand je dis il faut
agir sur la réglementation elle est pas
uniquement française elle est aussi
européenne puisque le gaz n'a pas de
frontières finalement donc il faut qu'il
soit accepté par tous les pays bien sûr
monsieur
rosdal ça marche j'avais une question
enfin deux questions la première c'est
beaucoup plus pour ma ma culture
personnelle c'est vous parliez de d'ici
2050 on arriverit quasiment à une
autosuffisance euh au niveau du gaz
c'estàd avec le gaz de synthèse enfin
différents gaz de synthèse euh alors
peut-être 2050 2060 enfin je sais pas
mais est-ce qu'on peut faire le calcul
au niveau européen c'est-à-dire est-ce
que la France est un bon élève là-dedans
est-ce que c'est un élève moyen ou
mauvais élève est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
euh pays qui sont meilleurs élèves qui
permettrai de moyenner d'arriver à une
autosuffisance européenne par rapport
àtion
alors votre question est assez complexe
parce que effectivement tous les pays
n'ont pas la même n'ont pas le même mix
énergétique ouais et il font pas appel
au gaz de la même façon et et notamment
il y a des pays beaucoup plus
consommateurs de gaz que la France comme
l'Allemagne par exemple et là on on voit
mal et en plus la France non seulement
elle consomme moins de gaz mais en plus
elle a des richesse agricoes qui sont
sans commune mesure avec l'Allemagne par
exemple d'accord donc on voit bien que
ce qui qui est vrai pour la France ne
sera pas forcément vrai pour l'Allemagne
et mais il y a chaque pays doit faire
cette démarche là et c'est l'objet
d'ailleurs du du groupe de travail que
que milen a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
on essaie de voir si dans dans les pays
qui ont signé cet accord là d'ailleurs
on l'a signé dans le cadre du Parlement
européen en avril dernier pour voir si
dans le cadre de cet accord
là comment chaque pays peut y arriveroi
quelque part et on a déjà vu diff des
différences notables évidemment et alors
ce qui est quand même frappant c'est
qu'un pays producteur de gaz
traditionnel comme les Pays-Bas s'engage
dans cette direction là quand même dans
une direction d'avoir des gaz
renouvelables en en proportion de plus
en plus important sur leur réseau ça
veut dire dans leur consommation c'est
là là je veux dire que là on parlait de
changement de paradigme mais alors là
c'est c'est c'est frappant quoi un pays
producteur de gaz qui s'engage dans
cette démarche là et après on a encore
beaucoup de choses à
construire ça veut dire qu'avec ça
devait
suffir mais c'est plutôt par rapport à
la réglementation cette fois-ci donc on
a vu des expériences dans le passé à
partir de gaz naturel sur des piles à
combustible et avec un gros problème qui
venait du mer cap et l'empoisonnement
par le soufre des des piles à
combustibles quel que soit d'ailleurs
les les températures
Soc on na pas mais ou des pemes et c'est
vrai que nous depuis un moment en
regardant les euh tout ce qui est euh
power to gaz pour reprendre donc la
dénomination on se dit même pour les
piles à combustible Nomad en fait je
prêche toujours pendant paroise du
nomadisme on se disant pourquoi est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas avoir un réseau de
distribution en fait à la gazinière on a
une prise à côté de la gazinière pour
recharger son son
hydrométallique un hydrométallique on
sait très bien qu' va faire la part des
choses entre le gaz naturel par exemple
et l'hydrogène c'estàd qu'il prendra que
l'hydrogène et le gaz naturel sera
quasiment un gaz inerte pour pour
l'hydre métallique à côté à la cétique
près enfin mais par contre si on
commence à mettre du souffre là-dedans
c'estàdire que même si on a un petit peu
de de soufre résiduel par le mécaptant
dans n'importe quel type de pile à
combustible spécialement les basses
températures c'est une une mort une mort
irréversible un empoisonnement
irréversible de de la pile est-ce que
là-dessus il y a une évolution ah oui
oui effectivement il y a une évolution
mais alors je vous faire une réponse de
Normand malgré tout parce que les
réseaux de distribution qui sont à côté
de la qui sont pour la gazinière là la
réglementation ne nous permettra jamais
euh d'avoir un un un du gaz qui ne soit
pas odorant parce que c'est une question
de sécurité oui donc ça là on peut pas y
compter dessus c'est c'est
inenvisageable en revanche là où on
travaille c'est à rendre le gaz français
compatible avec le gaz allemand
c'est-à-dire ou allemand ou autrre
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
pays qui n'autorise pas le le gaz y
compris sur la partie transport
c'estàdire sur la la partie haute
pression et actuellement nous on avait
fait le choix historiquement de faire
une une autorisation centralisée ce qui
coûte moins cher ce qui est plus fiable
et coûte moins cher néanmoins là on est
en train de revenir sur cette hypothèse
là parce que pour des raisons
d'interchangeabilité entre les pays pour
avoir des secours aussi et puis on voit
bien que l'épuisement des gisements
domestique de l'Europe conduit à aller
chercher du gaz de plus en plus loin sur
la planète et la France peut devenir un
point d'entrée justement puisque encore
récemment des acteurs importants ont
décidé de construire un terminal
méthanier à dunerque pour faire rentrer
des quantités extrêmement importantes de
gaz en France c'est évidemment pas pour
la France c'est c'est pour compenser la
baisse des gisements domestiques en
Europe et donc donc là l'idée c'est que
ce gaz là ne soit pas autorisé et qu'il
qu'il puisse transiter jusque là en
Allemagne si c'est nécessaire ou
ailleurs pour ne pas être limité par des
clauses de normalisation de normes
différent plutôt et donc ça veut dire
que ce que vous venez de dire ça sera
possible mais sur à partir des réseaux
de transport en direct sur des réseaux
spécifiques pas et et pas partout malgré
tout et ça ça répond pas tout à fait à
votre question je pense
éc pas sera forcément be de sou ou
est-ce qu'on peutaginerutre chose euh
pour l'instant on n pas trouvé de pas
trouvé mieux quoi
finalement juste par rapport à cell euh
oui effectivement la molécule elle est
elle est importante d'ailleurs dans les
pil à combustible domestique que nous on
construit on est forcément des capteurs
quand on a dulfurés pour mesurer sil y a
pas de fuite par contre je crois que les
quantités mises en en œuvre ne sont pas
les mêmes dans tous les pays et comme la
désulfuration ou désulfurisation dit en
français euh n est un élément important
du du cout total de possession d' d'une
microocogénération à pile puisqueil faut
changer les cartouch régulièrement pour
quand elles sont pleines je pense que là
aussi peut-être des choses à faire pour
que dans tous les pays européens on a
les mêmes niveaux en tout cas de de
mercap qui soit dans les concentrations
dans dans le gaz ça permettrait de
diminuer un peu le coût de possession
justement des des piles oui vous avez
tout à fait raison là on est en train de
revoir aussi cet aspect là parce que on
est on est bien sûr bien conscient que
les niveaux sont pas les mêmes et et
puis on est aussi bien conscient que
l'optimisation de de ce niveau
d'autorisation est une source d'économie
importante c'est parce que le produit
aorisant coûte très cher oui au debout
en fait du coup chez vous et et à
l'autre bout de la chaîne utilise bah
oui donc on a intérêt à le
minimiser bien monsieur Monsieur David
je crois que vous voulez poser une
question je vous en
prie je vais je vais intervenir donc je
me présente je suis David je m'occupe
pour le groupe arelis qui est une ETI en
forte croissance actuellement qui
recrute actuellement plus de 80
personnes pour le déploiement national
de réseau de transmission en Russie pour
la deè phase TNT russe donc je voulais
revenir un petit peu sur le marché de la
transmission pour compléter un peu ce
que dit Monsieur amaré puisqu'on est on
est partenaire sur un un projet Adem
autour de des stations autonomes et des
utilisations stationnaires de de de
l'hydrogène je voulais revenir un petit
peu sur les les verrous que nous on on
fait pH puisqu'on a neutralité de marché
vraiment les exigences de marché de nos
clients internationaux puisque 95 % de
notre activité de transmission est
tourné vers l'export aujourd'hui donc je
voulais mettre un peu d'enhase sur la
partie la simplicité d'utilisation et
les les questions de maintenance qui
sont liées à l'utilisation de de pile à
combustible donc avec les les phénomènes
d'encrassement donc je suis pas un
spécialiste du tout du du du du gaz mais
en travaillant dans dans différents
projets on s'est rendu compte et en
étudiant le sujet que c'est c'est des
verrous qui sont qui sont importants
aujourd'hui par exemple la cyclabilité
des des des des piles à combustible dans
une utilisation stationnaire et quelque
chose de de bloquant puisque dans la vie
des produits qu'on va déployer il est
c'est très difficile d'aller intervenir
dans un site isolé en haut d'une
montagne ou ou dans dans des conditions
difficiles de pouvoir remplacer
facilement ces ces éléments là donc je
voulais un petit peu savoir s'il y a des
évolutions technologiques ou ou des
choses un petit peu nouvelles parce que
notre première analyse jusqu'à
maintenant était de on a on a on a vu
que avec 4000 he annoncé en temps de
d'usage de l'électrolyseur c'était un
peu juste pour garantir un
fonctionnement sur 10 ans d'un d'un site
donc je voulais savoir si donc
normalement dans dans dans notre projet
avec avec avec atawe on va montrer on va
montrer normalement à travers ce projet
qu'on peut rendre applic
applicable l'utilisation de de
technologie hydrogène pour éviter
d'avoir des et avoir surtout des coups
de maintenance assez limités dans
l'usage de ces ces technologies
hydrogène donc je voudrais avoir un
petit peu des des des retours des
différents intervenants ici pour avoir
leur vision sur la cycl sur problème de
cyclabilité auquel on on dans notre
analyse nous avons vu que c'est ça
rendit le le système difficile à
utiliser sur le
terrain merci Monsieur David c'est
monsieur zdam vous avez entendu la
question oui peutêtre monsieur dans
votre question il y a deux éléments vous
avez parlé de pil commci pour démarrer
et puis vous avez fini par électrolyseur
et c'est vous parlez des deux oui je je
vais préciser donc dans les sites isolés
on peut pas conrire un pipeline pour
pour alimenter le site donc on doit
résoudre le problème de transport et
donc on est forcé on est forcé
d'utiliser un
électrolyseur et un système complètement
autonome et est-ce que je peux savoir
quelle quelle technologie
d'électroisseur vous utilisez ah bah
aujourd'hui bon c'est c'est dans la
technologie à taw donc on est on est sur
sur le de l'alcalin mais c'est pour des
questions justement de de de maturité
aussi technologique et pour ces
problèmes de de durée de vie
habituellement sur l'alcalin vous
devriez enfin le problème sur laquel
comme je l'ai exprimé il y a il y a un
peu de maintenance plus élevé que les
autres technologies mais au niveau de
durée de vie vous devez allègrement
atteindre les les 4 5 ans sans problème
maintenant si vous avez des soucis notre
durée de vie dans dans nos réseaux c'est
c'est minimum 10 ans je dis sans
problème 4 5 ans maintenant maintenant
il y a des ce qui veut dire que une
grosse maintenance ou dans je parle si
on raisonne en coup de TCO donc j'essaie
de de de montrer faut faut voir que ce
qu'on a en face à à réussir à à à
concurrencer c'est quand même des gen
set qui sont extrêmement peu chers et
donc quand un un opérateur fait son
calcul de de TCO il intègre ça dans
l'image et une grosse maintenance sur le
réseau on peut dimensionner aujourd'hui
et c'est l'objet du du projet d'essayer
de dimensionner pour pour éviter d'avoir
cette groste maintenance cette grosse
maintenance dans la durée de vie du
projet qui est aujourd'hui pour nous de
l'ordre de 10 ans hein quand on déploie
un réseau le la la la personne qui
déploie son réseau elle souhaite être
tranquille pendant 10 ans éviter d'avoir
des grosses maintenances on peut avoir
des petites maintenances mais une grosse
maintenance un remplacement
d'électrolyseur ou un un remplacement de
de pile à combustible ça ça rend le
modèle difficile
oui je comprends alors moi je peux pas
parler pour les pil comustibl parce que
c'est pas enfin bien que je connaisse
des choses mais je peux pas me prononcer
en tant qu'expert mais pour pour parler
de de
d'électrolyseur il est de toute façon
possible d'avoir des électroliseurs qui
durent 10 ans c'est pas un un point un
problème aussi bien dans les
technologies PM que dans les
technologies alcalin mais le le mais
derrière ça il faut imaginer ce qu'il
faut comme
comme auxiliaire à mettre en place pour
atteindre ces durées de vie je m'exprime
dans dans dans les technologies alcalin
alcaline vous avez du Koh si tentez que
votre eau soit un petit
peu enfin pas suffisamment pur le Koh il
va être attaqué très vite et vous allez
saturer le Koh par des ions extérieur
venant de de l'eau parce que ça ça
s'accumule et vous êtes obligé de
changer le KO c'est exactement pareil
pour une are technologie serapem l'acide
va se saturer en en ion extérieur et on
obligé de changer le le l'électrolyte
euh et pour le et pour le PM c'est
encore pire il faut changer le le stack
parce que vous allez vous allez
précipiter à l'intérieur des membranes
donc tout est possible tout est une
question de qu'est-ce que vous allez
mettre derrière comme auxiliaire il faut
mettre des purificateurs d'eau de de de
très grande qualité mais il faut pas
oublier d'aller changer les les filtres
de ce purificateur parce que là pareil
mais bon c'est des petites maintenances
donc dans les dans les dans les systèmes
qu'on déploie donc on a l'habitude de de
d'avoir des des systèmes par
refroidissement hydraulique pour les
puissances qu'on génère puisquon on
fabrique des émetteurs de de l'ordre de
de quelques wats
jusqu'à à plus d'un MW pour les les
émetteurs radio donc c'est on utilise
des technologies de refroidissement
hydraulique donc on a l'habitude des des
systèmes de de d'entretien de de de
système hydraulique de distribution avec
des exigences de fonctionnement où on va
être autour de de 99,9 % de taux de
disponibilité de la la station donc
c'est c'est des problématiques qu'on
qu'on gère déjà depuis depuis plus de 20
ans en terme de de déploiement de réseau
donc ça ça fait partie de notre notre
savoir-faire mais entre ça et changer
une une stack sur le terrain
c'est peut faciliter le changement de la
sta le rendre
simple option et c'est voilà ouais c'est
sûr que c'est sûr que pour les piles à
combustible estce qu'il a annoncé
aujourd'hui par le COA ou par des
partenaires qui développent des piles à
combustible c'est c'est plus de 5000 he
mais c'est pas 50000 he je veux dire
après les gens peuvent me corriger ici
encore une fois je suis pas expert
là-dedans par contre pour les
électrolyteurs alcalin justement leur
force jusqu'à maintenant était qu'ils
pouvaient fonctionner plus de 10000 he
sans changement de pardon plus de 100000
he sans changement de STAC euh même si
leur rendement est plus faible euh
là là là je suis surpris par par vos
propos sur l'alcalin donc je veux bien
qu'on en discute après mais je je sais
pas quoi dire pour les PEM pour les
électriseurs PEM pour notre technologie
on garanti 40000 he mais mais 100000 he
c'est un peu plus
compliqué bien écoutez je suis obligé de
constater que l'heure que l'URE avance
il faut à doné donné donneré un terme
nous avons encore toute l'après-midi
pour nous j'ai cru comprendre que vous
alliez vous revoir pour en parler
j'espère
voilà cet après-midi nous aurons deux
grands thèmes qui vont être qui vont
être abordés par plusieurs partenaires
celui de la maîtrise des risques
spécifiques aux usages donc de de
l'hydrogène et celui des modalités de
développement de la filiérie hydrogène
sur le territoire national donc de voies
qui doivent nous permettre peut-être
aussi de de nous projeter sur sur
l'avenir
voilà pour cette table ronde présidée
par jean-Marc Pastor et consacré à la
filière hydrogène énergie vous pouvez
bien sûr toujours revoir toutes les
tables rondes sur notre site
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 avec le début de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2014 très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaire